trillions of photons hit the earth every
second
each delivering life-giving energy but
for the unimaginable number who pass us
by
the journey is far from over around 80
minutes after leaving the Sun they reach
Saturn after four hours Neptune
once a photon leaves the surface of the
Sun it's free to travel as far as it can
and as far as it can can be literally
across the universe billions of light
years away
they shoot past the outer reaches of our
solar system in just 18 hours here the
Sun is a dim speck in the distance but
the photons keep on going out into deep
space
in 1,200 years some of the photons
reached the red dwarf star system Kepler
62 a solar system with potentially
habitable earth-like planets hurtling on
the photons past the Horsehead Nebula in
1500 years and the pilgrims of creation
in 7,000 at these distances the light
from our star is too small to be seen
with the naked eye but it would be
visible with a powerful telescope and
with the biggest telescopes that we can
create here on earth or in space we can
actually see the light from stars at the
other end of the universe
over 10 billion light-years away and so
the light from our Sun is travelling
across the universe so the light from
our Sun the light from the earth travels
essentially forever the next time you're
out under a clear sky and you look up
you might want to wave because somebody
out there might be able to see you and
wave back our tiny star is visible
across the universe if someone is
looking